let that sink in that's what Elon  tweeted after marching into Twitter's  headquarters carrying an actual sink and  as soon as Elon got control of Twitter  he began cleaning house we gotta start  cutting the crust off this sandwich the  CEO the Chief Financial Officer the  company's top lawyer they were all fired  just like that and now it's time for him  to fire Twitter's entitled employees see  Twitter is a horrible business that  barely makes any money but for some  reason they have over 7 500 employees  that get paid hundreds of thousands of  dollars each for an app that lets you  write 280 characters of text so yeah the  majority of these employees are  completely useless and should be fired  and once Elon does fire them Twitter  will be making him a lot of money  subscribe to find out what happens next